les rues s'ils pouvaient nous regarde et
je pense que ce soir il serait assez
content et servir une petite bière
gouverner c'est choisir et parfois faire
des choix qui ne nous plaisent pas ou
nous installer une société de contrôle
généralisé pour des mois voire des
années
[Musique]
vous allez opposer les français les uns
aux autres et puis vous allez pas former
des commerçants ont policiers our
délateur il faudra présenter à qr codes
sans indiquer son identité c'est le
degré maximum de l'absurde j'ai envie de
vous dire le remède est pire que le mal
il suffira évidemment quelqu'un de se
faire prêter aux gratuitement ou contre
rémunération un pass pour entrer dans le
restaurant et en plus on lui dira vous
pouvez donc ôter le masque notre
collègue a eu tout à fait raison de dire
que de toute façon c'est inapplicable
il y aura des faux qr code qui vont
circuler partout je sais la fragilité de
nos précieuses liberté et comment à la
faveur d'une crise sanitaire politique
ou économique
nos droits chèrement acquis de parler
c'est que les luttes peuvent être
restreints on n'a rien de temps on le
sait bien
le provisoire et l'exceptionnel
finissent souvent par durée je n'imagine
pas une société dans laquelle pour aller
prendre un café ou aller au cinéma il
faudrait montrer ses données
personnelles et je crains surtout que
nous nous habitue lyon à ce qui nous
paraissait il ya encore quelques
semaines à tous inimaginable
[Musique]